what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
going to make you guys an expert on the
character of echo in marvel comics now
here's the funny thing about this i have
no idea how this video is going to be
received
i have no idea people are going to care
or not care because the response to
hawkeye has just kind of been like i
mean it's cool so people might kind of
be like i mean i don't really care they
might be like yes i want to know about
echo so maya lopez first appeared in
daredevil volume 2 issue number 9 in
1999 and she was created by david mack
and joe casada now one of the big
misconceptions about the character of
maya is that her creation was designed
to be based on the character of
taskmaster and that's not entirely true
so there was an interview david mac had
done which focused on the question of
why echo was created in the first place
and the idea is that with david mack and
joe casada writing daredevil they wanted
to create a new character but it
couldn't just be any random character
instead they actually wanted to create
someone that could complement daredevil
in a lot of ways and matt murdock as
most of you guys know is blind and
through a combination of his senses
basically forms a kind of echolocation
that allows him to discern the world
around him and then operate as a
superhero and so the idea here was to
create a character who had basically
gone through the same experience the
difference being instead of being blind
she was deaf and so in daredevil issue
number nine which was actually kind of
uncommon at the time in the sense that
we got like a full-on origin for maya
what we ended up learning is that at
some point along the line her father had
basically been killed we didn't really
know a whole lot of the backstory in
terms of why her father was killed or
how all we simply knew is that her
father was executed and his business
partner actually ended up sending her to
a school for kids that were actually
disabled because of the fact that she
was deaf and that's when she first
learned what it was that she was capable
of that her ability to discern the world
around her was limited to her ability to
see and her ability to read the lips of
others but as she was watching this
person in a piano recital she basically
started to realize she could duplicate
the movements of others by watching them
simply just do whatever it is that they
do and so after seeing this guy's
recital she went up and immediately
perfected the exact recital he did right
so that established right off the bat
she can basically copy the movements of
anybody she sees after having only seen
it once and so during this story what
you ended up learning is that she was
set on daredevil by the kingpin and this
was basically a big ruse right that
wilson fisk had tricked her into
believing that daredevil was the reason
why her father was killed and so going
after daredevil what she had done is she
had actually sat down and watched
multiple videos of daredevil fighting
bullseye now the reason why david mack
and joe casada chose this is because
people sleep on bullseye man bullseye's
ridiculously capable he's like one of
the best fighters in all of marvel
comics right this guy is just it's crazy
how capable it is right between his
martial arts and his just pinpoint
accuracy the guy can is almost
completely unstoppable but because of
the fact that bullseye when it came to
like hand-to-hand combat was always able
to give daredevil a run for his money
and actually overtook him on a few
occasions he was the best person suited
for maya to basically copy both his
moves and daredevil's moves in her
preparatory fight against daredevil and
so what you actually end up seeing is
maya basically building on the death of
karen page operating at the behest of
kingpin and stepping in as a kind of
love interest for matt murdock and using
his basically you know devastated heart
as a means to enter into that position
now of course a fight ultimately breaks
out between the two when she makes the
move to try to take out daredevil and
then the truth comes out that's when you
actually end up finding out that her
father was a mob enforcer for wilson
fisk and was killed at the direction of
wilson fisk and so following that
basically maya shot wilson and then he
ended up being blind for a little while
but the important thing about this is
following that you basically went into a
handful of different stories by and
large she was still involved in the
stories of daredevil not as heavily as
she was in the beginning but in
daredevil 52 going into issue 53 and
then ultimately culminating in 55 she
ended up going on this kind of spirit
quest for herself which is something
akin to what matt murdock had gone on
when he was being trained by stick and
all those members of the cast and
whatnot and so with the way that david
mack had ended the events of the
character of echo in daredevil following
her kind of spirit journey or vision
quests which is technically what it was
called he concluded it in such a way to
where she would sort of go forward and
then whatever marvel wanted to do with
the character they could do but he had
kind of set the landscape to where she
wouldn't really be an anti-hero or a
straight villain the way elektra was but
could potentially become an actual hero
and so following that you got one of the
best echo stories ever by brian michael
bendis during new avengers in a story
called ronin now here's the funny thing
maya was actually the first person to
use the ronin identity in marvel comics
and by god did she earn it okay so check
this out so during the new avengers
story arc and technically it's it's like
issue number 11 where the running story
arc starts but what you end up finding
out is she's basically been sent to like
infiltrate the criminal underworld in
japan and it's amazing right so the idea
behind this is that for those of you
guys who never read brian michael
bendis's new avengers that came in the
aftermath of the avengers disassembled
story arc right which like went into
house of am and all that kind of stuff
the grand reshuffling of marvel comics
right so like reworking the avengers
roster reducing the x-men population
down to like 198 mutants in the world
just different things like that and so
what you had as part of brian michael
bennett's new avengers in the first
story arc was something called breakout
where the villain electro took down
power to the raft right the giant prison
that houses all these different super
powered beings and so the the following
stories after that and really a good
chunk of new avengers dealt with uh the
members of the new avengers team
tracking down these various people who
had escaped i want to say it was
something like 42 villains had escaped
and their goal was to like find them
locate them bring them in different
things like that and so as part of this
captain america had found daredevil now
daredevil's identity had already been
dumped out into the world different
things like that so matt murdock
couldn't just go and operate as a
superhero because the government would
find him and track him down and that
kind of a thing so he was largely
operating underground and so what had
happened was that captain america had
informed matt murdock that ken harada
the silver samurai had quite literally
been escorted away right like somebody
sent in a means by which for him to
leave and then he was taken to japan and
a lot of the questions they had was who
were the ones behind it right was it the
hand the yakuza nobody really knew what
was going on but the big concern they
had based on really the information that
matt murdock had as well as like shield
files and the information of captain
america was that the criminal underworld
ever since the arrest of harada had just
been in a state of disarray it was quite
literally a giant civil war right so you
had like all these factions the hand the
yakuza all these organizations basically
fighting against each other and vying
for power to control the underworld but
back in its day the whole underworld was
controlled by clan yoshida which was
governed by the silver samurai and so
the idea here is that silver samurai had
basically been taken to japan for the
purpose of unifying the criminal
underworld and that he would basically
be a puppet of the hand and being used
by the hand the hand themselves would
have control of the criminal underworld
now for those of you guys who don't know
who the hand is those guys are amazing i
absolutely love the hand they date back
to the days of feudal japan and what you
had were basically separated tribes of
japanese existing in the mountains
practicing martial arts which has
largely been forbidden at the time and
all these different clans were unified
by kaganobu yoshioka of course it also
tied into them like worshiping the beast
and getting mystical powers and things
like that the important thing is the
hand is like this mystical ninja clan
that can resurrect the dead and they'll
only ever come at you in one of two ways
either they'll send like a single member
in and they'll like assassinate you if
they want to keep it quiet or they'll
send in just overwhelming force so like
if the hand for example wanted to take
out the avengers which they could they
would send in like 500 ninjas and they
would just attack the avengers compound
in one fell swoop and any members who
died would be resurrected and sent back
in again so it's usually like a war of
attrition when the hand comes after you
but the idea is the hand basically
wanted to be the ones to run everything
the problem is that matt murdock
couldn't go in and deal with that
despite the fact that he's the best
person to do it because of his dealings
with the hand and the yakuza and the
silver samurai and all that kind of
stuff and so the introduction of echo as
part of this was basically matt murdock
saying look captain america i can't do
it but i know a guy and so that
basically led to echo being brought in
and infiltrating the entire organization
in japan only for for us to basically
find out that what was really going on
is the hand and hydra were working
together now a lot of this went into the
events of like enemy of the state right
so wolverine was basically taken by the
hand at hydra he was brainwashed and
then ultimately saved by the members of
the superhero community and that called
it a day i believe that's what led to
the death of elektra and then elektra
returned during the events of secret
invasion only to find out she was a
scroll uh of course that also gave us
the what if story where wolverine was
never stopped and wolverine basically
killed the superhero community we've
actually got a video on it wolverine
kills the marvel universe that came out
of enemy of the state but the
information gained here basically
allowed echo to get back to the avengers
and tell them what was going on now the
show of force and what what echo was
really capable of actually came to bear
better during this story than any other
story marvel's written and the reason
why is because when she tried to escape
she was ultimately discovered and so
what ended up happening is all these
hand ninjas just started descending on
her along with like the clan of the
silver samurai and hydra and so what
actually ends up going on is where she
had previously made an agreement with
captain america that she wouldn't kill
people if she didn't have to she went
all in she was a one-man army it was
like it's a one-woman army it was crazy
this girl took on something like three
dozen members of the hand she took on
clan yashida right and it was all just
because of her powers to duplicate the
moves of others that she was able to
overcome them all but literally bendis
was like yeah man this girl this girl is
just like she's a killing machine right
like you you give this girl the right
motivation and the right kind of
training she'll kill anybody in her path
and it doesn't matter who it is now you
also got a really cool set of events
because following that the hand had
actually followed echo back to avengers
compound so in one of the displays that
you don't normally get to see all that
often you got to see all the new
avengers fighting the hand and like it
wasn't one of those things where they
were like oh my god we're gonna die you
know but it was like it was cool to see
like captain america and iron man and
spider-man and luke cage and like
spider-woman jessica drew who were like
if we're not careful they will kill us
so like we need to work as a seamless
unit right it was it was a really really
cool fight that happened there although
now that i think about it i believe this
is actually what led into the elektra
solo series when you actually got the
origin of the hand for the first time
because during that that whole thing
what you ended up learning is that it
seemed like elektra was actually the one
who was leading the hand who didn't seem
to have a leader at the time and so
madame hydra was running the whole hydra
thing elektra was running the hand and
where madame hydra was basically
arrested it led to the belief that
electro was actually going to unify
hydra and the hand together and then
basically run them both and so the
character of of echo was actually kind
of kept there for the purpose of just
keeping an eye on things now all that
came to a head during the events of
civil war and while maya was not
necessarily directly involved in the
events of civil war uh she was involved
in so far as bender started wrapping up
loose ends involving her story and so
what you ended up learning is that
elektra was leading the hand and
discovered that maya was there the two
of them engaged in a fight and electra
killed maya but the whole reason why
elektra wanted to kill maya in the first
place is because maya could not be
easily turned there wasn't really a way
for elektra to get maya to ally with the
cause of hydra in the hand and then go
forward from there but by killing her
and then using the mystical abilities of
the hand to resurrect maya she was
basically a clean slate now the new
avengers were able to rescue maya but
because of the fact that her involvement
and her role in the new avengers had
been discovered by elektra in the hand
the belief was that it was only a matter
of time before they tracked her down if
they took her back to the states and to
essentially the new avengers mansion and
so because of the fact that it would
lead to the hand basically sending just
an overwhelming number of forces to new
york there would be collateral damage
innocent people would die different
things along those lines and so in an
effort to keep that happening they
actually took her to the harada fortress
knowing the hand would not be foolish
enough to try to invade the fortress of
the silver samurai and so during that
time she was basically left to allow the
whole resurrection process the drugs
that are used things like that to run
their course through her system which
actually led to a fight between her and
the avengers where she almost killed
them all and then in turn once it was
done another fight took place between
her and elektra which led to her killing
elektra now the significance of that
moment was not that she killed elektra
that wasn't very important what was
important is that was brian michael
bendis setting the stage for the events
of secret invasion because that's when
you learned it was not actually elektra
that instead it was a scroll
impersonating elektra hence the events
of secret invasion being slowly revealed
to the world following this echo had
basically demonstrated herself as being
a very capable member of the new
avengers and so that's why during the
events of bendis new avengers run she
basically stayed alongside the team she
was by no means like a major player i
mean she was but she was just kind of
there if anything it was probably bendis
trying to figure out what he was gonna
do with her or just kind of having her
there on the team while he focused on
the bigger picture going into like
secret invasion things like that the
world war hulk event was right around
the corner under greg pack right so
there were a lot of massive events
taking place in the the mid to late
2000s but she ended up basically living
alongside like jessica jones and clint
barton and that kind of a thing i
wouldn't say that ekko was useless but i
would say she was not as useful as she
could have been now a lot of it seemed
to be predicated on the idea or at least
i based it on her role in secret
invasion which there wasn't a whole lot
doing here in all honesty her role in
secret invasion really came in the main
secret invasion story itself she was for
example one of the people who realized
that spider woman jessica drew was
actually a scroll she was there in the
savage land when the scroll ship was
discovered and a big fight broke out and
then she basically joined the rest of
the people and fighting against the
scrolls themselves but it wasn't one of
these things where it was like secret
invasion echo number one right so it
wasn't like she had like her own story
arc going on in secret invasion she did
but it was just part of a larger run
with the whole story itself there were
some things that went on during like the
infiltration event for example her being
in a relationship with hawkeye different
things along those lines but it really
seemed more of ryan michael bendis just
kind of testing the character out kind
of shopping her around to get a feel for
what people were responsive to and
that's one of the things that i hope you
guys notice is that during this time in
echo's publication history it was really
bendis who was doing a lot of work with
her character and a lot of this really
came during moon knight vol 6. now
depending on who you talk to some people
will say they loved bendis's moon knight
other people will say it was okay i
thought it had some great moments one of
the things that i thought was really
really cool is that he was like a
one-man avenger operating in los angeles
right and one of the things that had
happened is captain america had
basically tracked down moon knight and
informed mark spector that a lot of
criminals that were in new york were
migrating to la and trying to take up
some measure of criminal activity out
there which doesn't surprise me it is
los angeles it's the home of shady stuff
so the thing about this
is that maya had actually taken up
acting alongside moon knight one part
because as captain america stated quote
unquote avengers never have to act alone
which i kind of thought was okay but two
she was already on her own mission the
two of them working together actually
came by happenstance when mark spectre
just came busting in and then she had
the blower cover and all that kind of
cool stuff but the other thing about
this and and what i imagine or at least
what i've seen to be one of the more
divisive things about bendis's run is
that mark spector's multiple personality
basically came into full array and a lot
of people saw this as bend is trying to
turn moon knight into like a legion s
character where he just had like all
these different personalities and he
didn't know which one was actually him
there was one point where he believed he
was spider-man there was another point
where he believed he was wolverine and
in fact during this particular run in
the story going all the way up to the
events of uh moon knight volume six
issue number nine there's basically one
instance where they end up tracking down
count nefaria who's kind of like this
long time villain in marvel comics who
is basically like this giant underworld
the kind of basically this kingpin of
the los angeles criminal underworld it
looked like he killed echo and then in
turn uh moon knight basically took on
like his wolverine persona and then
attacked count nefaria right and then
basically killed him but like with that
story taking place in 2012 with the
exception of like a single daredevil
story which was actually daredevil
annual vol 4 issue number one you never
really saw anything from her and a part
of me believes that marvel actually
forgot about her because of course you
had the events of secret wars by
jonathan hickman and like avengers and
new avengers and all that kind of stuff
so she really just kind of seemed to
vanish out of the marvel landscape for a
number of years now more recently during
the events of jason aaron's avengers run
which is technically avengers vol 8 you
had the enter the phoenix storyline
where she basically came in and was one
of the individuals who was selected to
be imbued with the the power of the
phoenix force this was really more of a
kind of like tournament of champions to
be honest that the phoenix would imbue
itself to different individuals and see
how they reacted as a test to determine
who was the most compatible with the
phoenix force itself in a lot of ways it
didn't necessarily make sense in
relation to the overall role the phoenix
plays that the phoenix as a cosmic
entity kind of already knows who's the
most compatible with it that's one of
the things that uh that chris claremont
established in the old x-men comics
bizarre adventures issue number 27 the
original origin of jean grey how it tied
into like the phoenix recognizing who
jean grey was uh was it the the missing
stories or x-men the missing years that
actually dealt with like gene grey's
involvement with the fantastic four her
temporary possession by the phoenix
there were just a lot of things that had
gone on and like excalibur stories and
so on that marvel had done over the
course of something like 20 or 30 years
that seemed to kind of fly in the face
of everything that jason aaron was doing
but the important thing here is that at
the end of this big battle royale this
big tournament that echo was selected to
basically be the new host for the
phoenix force in marvel comics now a lot
of this seemed to be done for the
explicit purpose of boosting the profile
of echo in order to kind of set the
stage for people to be interested in her
character during the events of hawkeye
uh if i'm being honest with you guys
that was a terrible decision in my mind
it's some kind of an event or some kind
of storyline should have been created in
the pages of the avengers where ekko
basically fought the team and with the
exception of some super heavy hitter
like thor she basically overtook
everyone because she easily could uh but
again that was the route they chose
which is kind of a weird thing because
honestly the phoenix force hasn't really
been interesting in mobile comics for
years uh but that basically went into a
story that focused on an event called
heroes reborn now heroes reborn was not
very good um it was a terrible follow-up
to the story involving echo and so it's
one of these things where marvel kind of
had this great opportunity to boost the
profile of what is even among general
comic book readers a pretty obscure
character in order to set the stage for
the hawkeye show uh and they basically
screw the pooch
i mean literally the entire gist of the
story is that phil coulson essentially
made a deal with mephisto to get the
pandemonium cube which basically allowed
him to rewrite reality and then he ended
up bringing in the squadron supreme
which was basically the marvel comics
version of the justice league and then
like echo fought some of them and then
basically the story ended when the cube
was destroyed it was not very good it
was not a very well received story but
regardless echo is one of these
characters where if we're being honest
with ourselves she peaked at the end of
brian michael bendis's moon night run
that's really where like the most
interesting elements of her character
kind of peaked out and that was
basically it i think a lot of that will
change now since she's in the hawkeye
show marvel comics will likely end up
doing a lot more with her but at the
moment if you guys really are interested
in the character of echo all you really
need to do is concern yourself with her
old school stories right her original
stories daredevil by david mack going
into brian michael bendis new avengers
and then going into somewhat the events
of of secret invasion and then brian
michael bendis moon night so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace